- You've taken both Barack
Obama and Will Ferrell
into the wild, which I think is awesome.
It's a grand scope or a
big kind of broad scale.
So be honest, in an apocalypse
who would survive longer?
- (chuckles) I don't know.
I think I've learned that the
wild isn't about competition.
It's not about who's better or stronger.
I think if I've learned anything it's that
you've got to work together,
you've got to use your collective skills.
So I think, I mean hey
listen, Will Farrell,
there's no one with a
better sense of humor
who's kinder and humbler
than Will, you know,
when we were on that adventure.
And a sense of humor really
matters when you're cold,
and you're tired and
you're under pressure.
- Yeah!
- President Obama, I think he was,
he was resourceful, he was curious.
He was really sort of determined
to go for things and try stuff.
So I think the combination
would be a killer team.
- You are such a politician, I love it.
I love that answer. (laughs)